هذا وقال مدير الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رثاء الجروسي ان البيان المشترك مع
ايران نتيجه ملموسه وصلبه لمحادثات
الطرفين واضاف ان بعض اجهزه المراقبه في
ايران سيجري تشغيلها قريبا واوضح ان هناك
تحسنا ملحوظا في الحوار مع الجانب
الايراني واضاف جروسيا ان الوكاله ستجري
تحقيقات باسرع ما يمكن بشان الاثار
النوويه في مواقع غير معلن عنها في ايران
تقييم الوكاله انه في الوقت الحالي لم
نحصل من ايران على الالتزام الذي نسعى
اليه ولد ايران تقييمه الخاص نحاول تحقيق
تقارب فيما يتعلق بما يسمى القضايا
العالقه بالنسبه لنا كانت العمليه طويله
اكثر مما يجب واعتقد ان تقدما تحقق في
حوار مع الايرانيين اعتقد انه تم الاستماع
الي وسنرى نتائج كما تعرفون في الاشهر
الماضيه كان هناك تقليص لبعض عمليه
التفتيش فيما يتعلق بالكاميرات والمتابعه
الالكترونيه
لا تعمل وقد اتفقنا انها ستعمل من جديد
وسنتفق على طرق تطبيق هذا